violent mobs demolished or damaged at
least 25
businesses burned down public buildings
and through bricks
at police offices which your police
officers won't stand for
and they didn't stand for it these are
not acts of peaceful protest but really
domestic terror
that's president trump in kenosha this
week my next guest
went away for a month and can't believe
how much more polarized the country has
become
in a few short weeks host of the reuben
report dave rubin joins me now with the
reaction to that and more
all right david first question where
were you for a month
[Laughter]
uh judge i was gonna tell the story's
location but i will
i i will tell you this much last time i
spoke to you which was a little over a
month ago i was considering leaving la
and as many of my friends have left but
i did decide to
at least stay here because if if some
good decent people can't stay
in los angeles can't stay in california
then then the polarization really will
have reached a point
where we're living in two different
countries so i'm gonna stay and fight
here look there were
there were old school reagan
conservatives a long time ago and i
think there's a chance we can
start bringing them back so we'll see
well hope spring's eternal but uh let me
ask you
how when you were off the grid wherever
that was
uh and you came back i mean did you
expect things to be different in the
country
well you know it's funny everywhere that
i went when someone would come up to me
people would say well first they can't
believe that i do this that i have no
phone no news
no information no current events no
nothing and then the second thing they
would say is
oh it's so much worse you're not going
to believe what happened and look a lot
of things happened and we know about the
riots and
and the protests and everything else but
what i'm concerned about and the reason
that i do this off the grid thing i've
done it for four years now a whole month
in august is that it gives you a little
perspective that i think
sometimes for people like us that are in
the news cycle all the time and we love
this stuff
but you know you end up reacting to
everything instead of getting a little
distance from it
and what i've noticed is just being back
a few days here
is that it really does seem like there's
a war on reality right now because
a certain set of the population people
that don't watch your show or don't
watch my show
they don't believe what president trump
was just talking about they don't get to
see the videos the violent videos
of the rioters and the protesters
attacking people and stopping cars on
the street
and burning down buildings because
they're not showing it on the other
networks
and what i'm worried about is if
depending on what channel you watch or
what youtube show you watch or what the
algorithm is giving you
we're going to end up living in two
countries not not just geographically as
i talked about before whether you're in
california or new york
but but sort of intellectually and
philosophically if your information is
just catered to make you think one thing
or the other
well you know the sad part about that is
that people are so committed now
to listening to one source for their
news or another
and you know they're not interested in
looking at the other
of the other channel or the other
station or the other you know
whatever the url might be um and and
that doesn't make for uh uh you know
country coming together
but but in terms of the election there
are 59 days
dave before the election and a lot of
talk while you've been gone about the
mail-in votes and all that
um you know the people that that are
dug in right now are dug in there is
that small
group in the middle who will i believe
decide this election
what's your sense about what's going to
be happening
yeah well it's a great question and i'll
tell you this i actually think that the
small group isn't as small as you might
think
i actually think most people not maybe
not most but i'd say a good chunk say 30
could still probably be swayed one way
or the other
and i think what's going to happen is if
you're the average person
and you're watching your business burn
or your local
restaurant not open or the rest of the
nonsense that we're seeing
and statues being torn down and general
mayhem if your choice is donald trump
who you may not like for whatever reason
you don't like the way he tweets
whatever it is
but if your choice is oh he's gonna
bring law and order or the other side
joe biden as your previous guest was
just saying
joe biden is now being led basically by
the worst elements
of the progressive movement and in
essence they're they're the foot
soldiers for
the the democrats at this point if the
choice is law and order and and some
semblance of loving america and
and the country that we've all known for
240 years
or that i think that that 30 is going to
break very hard
to trump that's not going to show up in
the polls because they they won't say it
in that
right but i think it'll show up in
november right
dave rubin thanks for coming back if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell